we know that covet 19 spreads through
close contact
making crowded areas potentially deadly
but when some members of a crowd are
immune that begins to change
this is called herd immunity it's what's
protecting much of the population from
diseases like measles and polio
and it's what's driving vaccine efforts
today
the notion is there will be enough
people in that community who are immune
so that when you
go to pass the disease on you won't be
able to
pass it on in a way that it will
propagate economies around the world
could then safely reopen
and some say it could put an end to the
pandemic
but the path to herd immunity includes
big hurdles
and experts say it could take years or
more if we get there at all
we'll explain
when scientists want to determine how
fast a virus might spread
they look at its reproduction number
this represents
how many people could catch the virus
from a single infected person
when no one in the population is immune
that helps us to
to understand how much additional
immunity or other measures do we need to
implement in place
to start to bring this epidemic under
control as opposed to having it
expand over time for example for the
polio virus
one infected person will pass the
disease to five to
seven people on average and from there
the disease will spread exponentially
for the novel coronavirus scientists say
an infected person will likely spread it
to two to four other people
that number can go down as more people
become immune
or also in response to
measures like wearing masks social
distancing
when enough people in a population gain
immunity the chances of infecting others
goes down
and once it falls below a certain point
it becomes harder and harder for the
virus to spread
as a result the majority of the
community becomes protected
not just those who are immune over time
the virus dissipates and really
essentially goes away or circulates at
very low levels in that community
scientists say there are two ways the
population can reach herd immunity
through broad infection or more commonly
vaccination
to get there through infection the
majority of a population needs to get
sick from a virus
and develop molecular defenses like
antibodies that fight off the disease
but this method would be deadly experts
estimate that less than five percent of
people worldwide have had covet 19.
yet scientists say to reach herd
immunity that number would have to be
between
60 and 70 percent if we need to get to
60 or 70
infections uh that's obviously more than
you know
four billion people getting infected
that would be tens of millions of people
dying uh it would be hundreds of
millions of people getting very very
sick
uh it would be devastating be
devastating for the entire global
population to be devastating for the
economies
and it is wholly unnecessary there's
also no guarantee that broad infection
would lead to eradication
we don't have many examples of
complete immunity to viruses
through natural infection because people
continue to get born in a population so
every year you have a new set of babies
who are born
and they're going to be susceptible to
that infection experts say the more
efficient way to hurt immunity is
through vaccination
that's how scientists eradicated
smallpox because of vaccines
childhood mortality has dropped
dramatically kids no longer die of
measles they don't die of
a lot of the of the diseases that kids
used to die of obviously smallpox was
one of the
horrible scourges of humanity throughout
the entire human history
we don't talk about smallpox anymore
because because our vaccination campaign
ultimately led to the eradication of
smallpox but experts say
they don't know enough about the
coronavirus to predict the likelihood of
reaching herd immunity
and that there are large barriers to
getting there even with a vaccine
one challenge is that scientists don't
yet know how long natural immunity might
last
there's a big difference between being
immune for six months
and being immune for 10 years for other
respiratory viruses like the flu
antibodies tend to decrease over time
scientists have observed this in some
patients recovering from cobit 19
but there isn't enough data yet to be
certain about what that means for
immunity
how long a covet 19 vaccine will last is
still unclear
but it may be measured in months or
years rather than
a lifetime another challenge not all
vaccines and development will work the
same
and their effectiveness could differ the
better a vaccine
is in terms of the level of protection
and the duration of protection
the the further it gets you towards that
point of
of herd immunity right but even a
less than perfect vaccine if given to
enough people in the population can
help reduce the the spread scientists
are working quickly to test dozens of
vaccines
already in development but it could take
years to figure out which ones are more
effective
so even if people get vaccinated some
could be more susceptible to catching
the virus
but even as cases surge around the world
some experts are optimistic
we suspect that people who have gotten
covet 19
remain protected for for many months at
least because we haven't seen a
large number of repeat infections
we also know that it's possible to give
people multiple vaccinations
so i'm hopeful that we can develop
over time a vaccine that even if we do
need to give
multiple doses will be highly effective
in generating the the levels of immunity
that we need
to defeat this disease if this happens
global herd immunity may be possible
but until then health experts have
stressed that measures like social
distancing and wearing masks will be key
to slowing down the spread